pour ne rien vous cacher la terre ont ce
ton là n'était pas si amusante que ça du
point de vue des sept ont particulier
c'était pas du tout organisé et il n'y
avait personne pour s'en occuper
il restait bien quelques dinosaures en
retraite mais il disait que les 7 et
tout ça c'était plus de leur âge et que
de toute façon été appelés à disparaître
ce qu'ils firent en effet par la suite
comme chacun sait alors les gy be
décidèrent de remettre un peu d'ordre
dans tout ça et passer un premier coup
de peinture pour que ça fasse plus qu
ils en profitèrent pour repeindre aussi
les dinosaures qui le remerciait re
beaucoup de leur attention la terre
comme ça a été quand même peu plus
présentable et la grande inauguration
pouvait commencer